welcome to this video playing pay gas
from turkey plenty for for a change okay
please forget something that I can
probably play without any super deep
theoretical knowledge quince is seven
yeah that sets playable of course
sometimes a bit slow in the hall wow
that's surprising that he actually
allows an opening of the position while
being well being behind the development
okay let's let's open things just
instamood while when this is already
critical for Black Ant is still play it
plays in the second where does he go
here widest White's winning already
night see 893 with 95 coming this looks
this looks right dreadful really okay
but let's see 95 Bishop g5
95 Queen d8 Bishop g5 maybe there is
something even more convincing a Bishop
f4 and of course Bishop f4 and they're
really there must be a direct kill here
just porn or something is not enough and
ninety seven assists scones black
resigns yeah it's it's the old sorry I
know people are totally annoyed that I
keep saying that but there is no point
in playing a move in three seconds d 5
is just so bad you cannot open the
position with being not developed at all
I mean give it to a comp + 1 point 3 and
it only gets worse I guess Bishop g4
probably ok but he went Bishop g7
instantly and after that white is just
winning c4 and DC 5 plus 6 that's it
yeah not much to say about it if you
play moves in two seconds and in a
position that you don't know where the
other side is much better developed
you're going to lose the game quickly
it's just like that like a cell has no
defense defense here anymore um Quincy 7
is so it's still okay I guess but Tia
black needs to get try to keep the
position closed in a way something like
d6 or e 5 maybe not super directive move
but something like that should probably
be be tried or g6 maybe is also
something like this this might be
rendered its not clear what the queen is
doing on c7 s you never really want to
recapture with it you don't mind to have
the double pawn something like that also
looks quite nice for my due to the good
development but it's not comparable to
what happened in the game where he was
just just
losing out right ok quick game thanks
for watching